[музика]
Привіт це програма У фокусі Європа і
раді що ви з нами
для багатьох людей в Туреччині
повсякденне життя стало занадто дорогим
в основному через важку економічну
ситуацію з якою зіткнулася країна та
стрімко інфляцію за каденції президента
рдогани ціни на продукти харчування
злетіли до небес одночасно з цим зросли
ціни на енергоносії а також вартість
оренди квартири чи купівлі будинку
особливо це стосується
найпопулярніший курортних зон Туреччини
піднімають основному росіяни
Туреччина одна з до багатьох країн куди
досі можна долетіти на пряму з Москви і
для росіян анталін узбережжі
Середземного моря це не лише красиве
курортне місто але притулок від
наслідків війни Росії проти України але
Зростання ціни нерухомість призводить до
того що домівки місцевих жителів Анталії
таких як мусає шир і нервін таші
незабаром можуть стати їм не по кишені
Анталія на узбережжі Середземного моря
одне з найбільших міст Туреччини навіть
взимку тут можна провести цілий день на
пляжі тож не дивно що ринок нерухомості
в Анталії стрімко зростає але головна
причина щотижневого росту цін Усе більше
кількість росіян які приїжджають сюди
відтоді як почалась війна в Україні щоб
купити або орендувати житло
це поставило таких мешканців як Муса
єшар і narmin таші у скрутне становище
У деяких випадках ціни на нерухомість
зросли на 800-900 %
навіть державні службовці вже не можуть
дозволити собі жити тут я знаю кількох
які попросили про переїзд через високу
орендну плату
я шар і таші створили групу у соціальних
мережах під назвою жертви оренди Вони
відвідують пенсіонери якому орендодавець
вручив повідомлення про розірвання
договору він не може дозволити собі
орендну плату після п'ятикратного
підвищення
квартира тепер дістанеться іноземцю вони
за місяць витрачають більше грошей ніж
ми за рік
давно пора державі втрутитися
вони повинні надати соціальне житло щоб
ми малозабезпечені сім'ї теж мали де
жити
вони вважають що основна причина різкого
зростання цін на нерухомість це
збільшення кількості іноземних покупців
більшість цих покупців росіяни яких
зараз в Анталії проживає близько 60
тисяч за словами агентів з нерухомості
це різко вплинуло на ринок
квартири які були виставлені на ринок за
5 тисяч Лір А це приблизно 250 євро
раптово могли здаватися в оренду
іноземцям за втричі більшу ціну
і коли про це дізналася сусіди Вони
почали вимагати таку ж орендну плату
орендні активісти відчувають дедалі
більші розчарування кожен хто переїздить
сюди повинен мати право жити так як він
хоче це абсолютно нормально але коли це
відбувається за рахунок наших дітей
нашого майбутнього це стає проблемою
міська православна парафія слугує місцем
зустрічі для багатьох росіян кілька
чоловіків приїхала сюди на випадок якщо
Росія оголосить мобілізацію розповідає
нам митрополит інші приїхали до
Туреччини через міжнародні санкції проти
їхньої країни Давид Царьов приїхав до
Анталії ще до початку війни для нього
церковний хор це зв'язок із домом
Він каже що закріпитися в Анталії стає
дедалі важче навіть росіянам
[музика]
почати людям складно знайти житло
неможливо знайти роботу
перший місяць життя тут людина приходить
до нас і питає як мені зробити це і це
Але у нас на жаль немає відповідей на ці
питання для цього треба володіти якимось
бізнесом чи нерухомістю
Царьов ІТ спеціаліст йому подобається
сидіти на турецькій рів'єрії і працювати
на своєму ноутбуці але він усвідомлює що
хоча він не може дозволити собі
орендувати житло за 5 сотень євро
багатьом турецьким громадянам це не по
кишені
зі свого боку ми приїжджі маємо уважно
ставитися до вимог місцевої влади і
орієнтуватися на ринок
Ми не можемо бути відповідальними за
економічні наслідки для регіону
але як вважає мусая-шар у житловій кризі
є багато винуватців і частина з них
політики він хоче вступити в
конфронтацію з головою району де
оселилося найбільше росіян
раніше іноземці приїжджали сюди у
відпустку вони бронювали путівки на 1-2
тижні
вони не купували будинки і неселилися
тут
якщо відсоток іноземних орендарів або
власників житла в районі перевищують
20%. ринок нерухомості закривається для
іноземців
три райони тут в Анталії вже мають таку
заборону з липня минулого року
Чи можете Ви хоча б допомогти таким
громадянам як я знайти квартиру
ну це не моя робота це справа агентів
коли я шар забирає доньку зі школи у
нього немає для неї новин щодо нової
квартири він робить Хоробрий вигляд але
його вічей зростає
збільшення орендної плати в Анталії
незабаром може змусити таких жителів як
мусая шар покинути рідне місто
труднощами знайомим і багато румунів
Ця країна одна з найбідніших
європейських Союзі а в сільській
місцевості навіть візит до лікаря може
стати критичним для місячного бюджету
у селі котареве у багатьох людей немає
медичної страховки а найближчий лікар
знаходиться Та далеко що дорога до нього
коштує надто дорого На щастя є лікарі
які допомагають як наприклад ось ці що
стоять за моєю спиною їхній девіз такий
якщо у пацієнт не може прийти до лікаря
То лікар повинен прийти до пацієнта
безкоштовно
у столиці Румунії бухаресті 6:30 ранку
Віра магдале зустрічається з другом який
повезе її до найвіддаленіших куточків
країни Вона навчається на медсестру і
працює волонтеркою у благодійній
організації Каравана кумеддічі або
Караван лікарів попереду У Віри довгий
робочий день за які їй не заплатять але
вона прагне допомагати знедоленим людям
у своїй країні
в рамках кампанії ми пропагуємо хороше
здоров'я
пропонуючи скринінг тим хто його
потребує
[музика]
за допомогою інших волонтерів таких як я
ми можемо забезпечити низку складних
медичних обстежень до яких люди інакше
не мали б доступу
цього разу вона прямує до хуторали
віддаленого села на півдні Румунії у
місцевій гімназії на день облаштовують
медичний центр
до вечора троє лікарів і 5 медсестер
відряджених організацією оглянуть понад
75 пацієнтів
однією з перших на огляд приходить
лентіція вазілахи
72-річна жінка живе сама відтоді як у
серпні помер її чоловік поруч не було
жодного лікаря який міг би йому
допомогти
Він дуже швидко помер
У нього був тромболівій нозі який не
лікували
потім у нього не витримало серце і він
миттєво помер
лентіція вазілахи має лише 200 євро на
місяць тому немає грошей на медичну
страховку чи приватних лікарів багато
кому тут знайома подібна ситуація
такі місця як хутарелли типові для
сільської Румунії
тут майже немає роботи доходи низькі
багато хто не має медичної страховки і
люди обходяться тільки тим що вирощують
на своїх фермах і у садах міхаела
верестянов одна з таких вона живе на
фермі зі своїм хворим чоловіком і
бабусею я практично ніколи не ходила до
лікаря я бувала з чоловіком але сама не
зверталася до лікаря із моменту
народження моєї останньої дитини Відтоді
я навіть не проходила жодних обстежень
для міхаеле те що вона може пройти
безкоштовне обстеження справжнє диво
Це буде перший скринінг на рак у її
житті
Якщо ви поїдете до бухареста вам
потрібно буде мати гроші на скринінг
вони не зроблять цього безкоштовно як
зробили для нас тут
у кого б не виникли ідея приїхати до нас
у хатареле Це була чудова ідея
Лорен сурадо організував візит медичного
каравану за допомогою приватних
пожертвувань робота лікарів оплачується
але їхня асистенти працюють безкоштовно
під час кампанії понад 60 лікарів і
волонтерів проводять вісім вихідних у
сільській місцевості їх завжди
відправляють у бідні села У підсумку до
1400 людей отримують безкоштовні
обстеження та консультації
є міста Перепрошую села без сімейних
лікарів як ми їх називаємо або
дільничних терапевтів
[музика]
є район де на одну-дві чи навіть три
тисячі людей є лише один лікар
А ще якщо говорити про такі дослідження
як УЗД людям часто доводиться їхати за
30-40 кілометрів
сьогодні медсестра Віра магдали
допомагає гінекологині Ларисі будулуці
вона робить УЗД в ході скринінгу на рак
молочної залози і вже до полудня
обстежила 30 пацієнток
наймолодший було 22 роки найстаршій 63
більшість із них ніколи раніше не
проходили скринінг на рак молочної
залози і навіть не знали що мали б його
пройти
протягом усього дня пацієнти продовжують
сходитися до центру ці літні жінки також
скористалися можливістю відвідати лікаря
безкоштовно Хоча всі вони почуваються
чудово
Ця жінка остання пацієнтка на сьогодні
після 11 годин купіткої праці робочий
день Віра магдали нарешті закінчився
коментар ферити Я втомлена але щаслива
День пройшов не марно він був
захоплюючим і не схожим на жоден інший
який у мене будь-коли був я сподіваюся
повторити цей досвід адже він допомагає
мені кращого усвідомлювати певні речі
загалом результати також були
позитивними лише в одного пацієнта
виявлено потенційну серйозного
онкологічну хворобу яка могла б
залишитися непоміченою якби не
благодійна організація
будь-які батьки скажуть вам що
виховувати дитину може бути нелегкою
справою це стосується і хай не ройтер
вона намагається забезпечити свій донці
всебічно розвинене життя але себе вона
орієнтується в темряві канна ройтер
незряча як і її чоловік і ще донька Міла
єдина в сім'ї хто може бачити але навіть
якщо Це додає трохи більше перешкод як
його повсякденному житті разом і
вдається їх долати
на годиннику 7 ранку звичайний
навчальний та робочий день Ханна готує
обід для своєї доньки Міли
любий А де яйце біля раковини
біля раковини Ага знайшла
кумедно мати вдома двох незрячих людей
Адже завжди Треба дуже чітко вказувати
де ти щось залишив інакше інший буде
шукати цю річ цілу вічність обмацуючи
руками всі поверхні Іноді я задумуюсь як
добре було просто швидко озирнутися
довкола
зранку сидить за комп'ютером спеціальна
програма підказує йому що відбувається
на екрані
Міла так перевірчити все взяла пенал і
все інше
Мені не потрібна О дякую мені вона ще
знадобиться
Що тобі потрібно сьогодні папка взяла
пенал взяла коробку з олівцями чи як там
ви її називаєте так взяла
чи допомагає Міла мамі і тато коли вони
не можуть щось знайти
ну спершу Вони мають самі пошукати але
якщо в них не виходить я допомагаю
нам би все одно довелося це робити Якби
Міли тут не було
а для нас це важливий принцип а зрештою
вона нам не Прислуга А вона просто
дитина і якщо не хоче то не мусить
перед тим як сім'я виходить з дому Ханна
знаходить час щоб нанести макіяж Вона
навчилася цьому на курсах для незрячих
людей навіть якщо Ханна не бачить як
виглядає вона відчуває що гарний
зовнішній вигляд допомагає боротися із
упередженнями
якби Наприклад моя дитина бігала на
вулиці з томатним соусом на футболці
люди дуже швидко вирішили б що вона
брудна тому що її бідна Мама не може
цього побачити
тому я стала певною мірою
перфекціоністкою
Я краще 5 разів усе перевірю тому що
люди дивляться на нас як ми виглядаємо
що ми робимо чи зможемо ми безпечно
перейти дорогу
поки Міла в школі гендон готує обід
Він працює масажистом чоловік осліп
майже 15 років тому після відшарування
сітківки
Ганна незрячу від народження Вона працює
у сфері зв'язків із громадськістю і як
письменниця
якою була їхня перша зустріч
було просто Відчуття це жінка з чудовим
голосом
звісно я не міг її бачити але Я відчував
що вона красива
тут я сказав собі нічого не вийде
через три роки вони одружилися і згодом
з'явилася Міла разом із деякими
хвилюваннями
перша - це величезний виклик для всіх
батьків не важливо зрячих незрячих чи з
будь-якими іншими порушеннями і коли
люди замість того щоб сказати О вітають
у вас буде дитина це чудово кажуть О а
ви все продумали як це буде відбуватися
це викликає занепокоєння у другій
половині дня Ханна і Міла гуляють із
собакою поводирем дайкою сім'я живе у
центрі Берліна
проїдься дорогу і Зачекай на мене там це
нудно Бувай як завжди
Я скоро підійду Бувай Ходімо дайте
завжди хвилююча відпускати її ось так
але Без довіри нічого б не вийшло
Я знаю що вона дуже обережна на дорозі
і досі у нас не було жодних проблем
Міла все більше усвідомлює як люди
реагують на її сім'ю і знає чого вона
хоче від них
то вони проявляли більше поваги
бо моя мама теж нормальна людина
зряче чи Незрячі Всі батьки хочуть щоб
їхні діти почувалися гідно Ханна каже що
у них звичайна сім'я
зради своєї доньки вона хотіла б бачити
більше прийняття і менше упереджень
звісно її дратує що люди витріщаються на
нас коли ми виходимо на вулицю всією
сім'єю
ми завжди у центрі уваги
Іноді я думаю що навіть добре що ми
цього не бачимо
я в дуже хотіла щоб люди сприймали це як
щось цілком нормальне
зрештою у світі завжди були сліпі батьки
і Для нас це завжди було нормальним
явищем а не проблемою але на жаль дехто
досі не сприймається так і Мені б дуже
хотілося щоб це змінилось
[музика]
китайські Дисиденти які вдається втекти
до Європи думає що вони в безпеці
принаймні так вважав Венг джинг'ю він
приїхав до Нідерландів кілька років тому
після того як потрапив у неприємності
через критику китайського уряду але
Що досі відчуваю загрозу з боку пекіна
згідно з доповіддю Китай має нелегальні
поліцейські відділки по всій Європі які
чинять тиск на дисидентів
Нідерландах це викликало неабияжіотаж
голландські політики в газі дали
зрозуміти що вони хочуть припинити
діяльність таких підконтрольних Китаю
поліцейських дільниць
прямує до свого супротивника посольства
Китаю у гаазі
21-річний хлопець втік із Китаю у 2019
році коли йому було лише 17 він
розміщував в інтернеті матеріали у яких
критикував реакцію уряду на протести у
Гонконзі зараз він живе у Нідерландах і
каже що його антурядова активність у
Європі також спричинила проблеми для
його сім'ї на батьківщині
Я хочу що вони пояснили мені чому вони
затримали заарештували ми їх батьків
друге - це протест протидії китайського
уряду щодо інших китайських дисидентів
тому що уряд Китаю заарештовує багато
дисидентів і їх переслідує
Венг каже наші знімальній групі що
очікує виклику голландської поліції
щойно Він підійде до посольства
поліція вже їде його передбачення
відбувається Всього за кілька хвилин
поліція каже що для них це звичайна
справа запитувати людей що вони роблять
якщо ті затримуються біля іноземних
посоль розташованих тут у газі
китайський паспорт венга визнано
недійсним Він каже що від його імені
регулярно надходять фальшиві
повідомлення про замінування готелю по
всьому світу на його телефоні видно
сотні дзвінків з погрозами які за його
словами Він отримує щодня Він стверджує
що нещодавно його переслідував у цьому
кафе хтось хто найго думку був урядовим
агентом
просто хочемо жити нормально життям вони
постійно щось роблять погрожують мені
переслідують навіть посилають людей
стежити за мною чи створюють мені
проблеми або просто дзвонять і кажуть Я
з поліції Ви повинні приїхати до нас
інакше ми прийдемо до вас додому Це
дійсно зводить мене з розумом Лора Харт
працює у правозахисній неурядовій
організації сейвгарт дефендерс яка
опублікувала звіт за 2022 рік у якому
стверджується що китайська Влада
створила понад 100 закордонних
поліцейських відділків вони також
знайшли докази у власній звітності Китаю
що китайська Влада змусила понад 230000
китайських громадян повернутися до Китаю
у період з квітня 2021 року по липень
2022-го
А ми знайшли звіти китайської влади про
те що ці пункти працюють для надання
таких послуг як поновлення паспортів
водійських прав тощо але крім того вони
формують зв'язок із бюро громадської
безпеки та китайської прокуратурою і
судами на батьківщині щоб відстежувати
настрої та суспільну думку громаді і
намагатися переконати їх повернутись
назад до Китаю ми Звернулися до
посольства Китаю у Нідерландах але
відповіді не отримали Міністерство
закордонних справ Китаю категорично
заперечує існування закордонних
поліцейських відділень Китай
дотримується міжнародного права і
поважає суверенітету всіх країн так
званих китайських закордонних
поліцейських відділень не існує Міністр
закордонних справ Нідерландів повідомив
що вони Звернулися до Вітаю з вимогою
закрити поліцейські дільниці абсолютно
чітко дали зрозуміти Китаю все що ми
побачили будь-яке державна діяльність
може відбуватися лише тоді коли країна
яка є приймає знає про неї і
погоджується з нею Це був явно не той
випадок тому ми сказали їм закрити їх
негайно Що вони зробили і зараз ми
розслідуємо точні деталі цієї справи
Венг наполягає на тому що відділення
досі працюють і хоче щоб влада
Нідерландів доклала більше зусиль вони
повинні попросити поліцію обшукати
закордонні поліцейські відділки вони
повинні подати в суд на злочинця тобто
на китайську закордонну поліцію Я
сподіваюся що вони зможуть депортувати
китайського посла тому що він вже робив
фальшиву заяву голландську поліцію про
те що у мене є бомба Європейська комісія
заявила що хоча і засуджує будь-який
іноземне втручання на території своїх
країн-членів вона не буде розпочинати
загальноєвропейську акцію це питання
національної безпеки та суверенітету
країн-членів ЄС
деякі країни вже розпочали розслідування
і комісія дуже позитивно оцінює Цей факт
оскільки надзвичайно важливо пролити
світло на це тривожне явище
для венга переслідування і погрози з
боку китайської влади ніщо у порівнянні
з тим занепокоєнням яке він відчуває не
знаючи як його дії вплинули на його
сім'ю він не може зв'язатися з ними
Спробуй Подзвонити мамі
номер який ви набрали не обслуговуються
будь ласка перевірте номер і наберіть
його ще раз
танець зближує та об'єднує нас а для цих
танцюристів він також зберігає культурну
спадщину
багато вірмен люблять традиційні танці
своєї країни і вважають їх важливою
частиною своєї ідентичності
навіть урбельники живуть за кордоном
приїжджають на Батьківщину і збираються
разом з іншими в столиці Вірменії є
ірманії на вечори пісень танців і сміху
А на сьогодні це все від імені всієї
команди фокусі Європа дякуємо вам за
перегляд Бережіть себе і Побачимося у
наступному випуску до зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціативу Київ 2023 рік
[музика]